hello and welcome we're here at the
security zone at Google next with
projector who is one of Google's leading
experts in denial of service attacks hi
projector hi Cassie and thank you for
having me when company is deploying
internet-facing services one of the
biggest problems they encounter is
denial of service attacks so our
customers have a tough job they want to
quickly and responsibly serve their
end-users and at the same time they need
to defend their internet-facing services
against malicious attacks and denial of
service attacks are getting much larger
they're getting much more sophisticated
and security teams need to be prepared
for them so let's look at an example
let's see you the infrastructure manager
for an online retailer and it's Black
Friday the busiest day of the year for
you and you've got an important job you
need to make sure that the website and
app stay up and running so Black Friday
has started and here we can see all of
the successful transactions represented
as boxes and coming into the application
servers everything looks to be running
smoothly now but let's see what happens
once an attack is launched awesome do
your worst the first attack I'm going to
launch there's a high-volume DDoS attack
I'm going to use this to try and
overwhelm the servers with malicious
traffic we can see that the application
instances have been overwhelmed by the
malicious traffic and the attacker
servers if this amount of traffic keeps
hitting the application instances
they'll get overloaded and they'll go
down that's correct
shoppers on the website are already
getting a slow load time and the website
is going to start crashing now as the
infrastructure manager you do have some
tools at your disposal to manage this
what you think would be the best way to
go handle this
I'm gonna go with infrastructure DDoS
protection using Google global load
balancer great choice
after you enable the Google global load
balancer the application instances are
back up and running and shoppers are now
able to access the site without a
problem now in this example you turned
on this defense in the middle of a live
attack but in reality you would have
actually only set up your services
behind the global load balancer prior to
Black Friday but Black Friday isn't over
yet
in fact our shoppers are just getting
started let's see what happens when the
attacker launches an application attack
this time this time I'm gonna launch a
sequel injection attack so now our
attacker is sending in sequel injection
packets in an attempt to bring down our
service and steal data with sequel
injection one little flaw in one little
feature of your application can
compromise all the data for your app
again you've put some tools at your
disposal what do you think is a good
defense for this type of attack I pick
cloud armor sequel injection defense
good choice again this cloud armor rule
acts as a defense to these types of
attacks by automatically identifying
malicious sequel injection packets and
blocking them before they hit your
application instances without cloud
armor you would have to first detect
sequel injection attack and then react
remediate and also fix your code and
data got it so this means just enabling
this single rule would defend our app
against all sequel injection attacks
that's correct but the day isn't done
yet and our sophisticated attacker is
going to come at us again for this last
attack I'm going to use a multi vector
attack which is going to hit the
application instances using multiple
different types of attack vectors all at
once now we can see that a multi vector
attack is hitting the servers and trying
to take them out and it looks like all
of this traffic is coming from one
region again the service is slowing down
and our shoppers aren't able to submit
their orders after analyzing this attack
we find out that it's coming from a
single location with a specific type of
cookie and user agent aha so maybe we
could create a custom rule in cloud
armor that looks for this cookie and
user age
in the traffic coming from the region
exactly that's good now you see the
cloud armor custom rule blocking the
traffic that matches our specified
pattern which helps keep our service up
and running I feel like now I know a lot
more about what our retail customers
have to deal with on Black Friday I have
a lot more empathy for them it's pretty
challenging with Google Cloud stools to
help defend and scale against this
infrastructure and application denial of
service attacks in place you can
actually focus on building great
software and great customer experiences
thanks so much for walking us through
this demo and projector and Thank You
Serena for this very admirable attack
attempt thank you
[Music]